SPEAKER 1: So this is the
first GDD I'm attending.
SPEAKER 2: I'm
coming from Egypt.
We spent 24 hours to be here.
SPEAKER 3: I knew many of
my friends will be here.
SPEAKER 4: The fact that I
got to know so many people.
SPEAKER 5: So many mentors.
SPEAKER 6: Networked
with so many people.
SPEAKER 7: Coming to the
event, I actually get, like,
meet them face to face.
You know, have that
personal connect.
SPEAKER 8: That's something that
makes this thing really worth
it.
SPEAKER 9: There's
always something
that you can incorporate.
If not as a developer,
but as a designer,
you can still learn how
to build communities
of a certain interest.
SPEAKER 10: Everybody
is like-minded.
Everybody wants to
achieve something.
SPEAKER 5: This is
a great opportunity.
This place is very cool.
SPEAKER 11: I attended
a few sessions
from people who are,
like, legends in Google.
SPEAKER 12: We learned
so many things from them,
like how to work
in the community,
how to develop in our field.
SPEAKER 13: I was looking into
some certification programs
by Google.
So I'll be going into that.
SPEAKER 14: Love the
demo booths here.
SPEAKER 5: I know
web development.
But I haven't explored other
domains, like machine learning,
TensorFlow, and everything.
And here, I get to
attend everything
related to all the domains.
SPEAKER 15: I'm final
year student at College
of Engineering, Changodar.
I want to teach what I gain
from here to my teammates,
and thus improve my project.
SPEAKER 16: I also spent
a few hours with Googlers,
like Ashish and Suchit.
And they all are
really amazing guys.
I love them all.
SPEAKER 17: Something
that I really
like about this
event is the gender
ratio is pretty high for women.
I see a lot of
women participation,
and that makes me really happy.
SPEAKER 18: I'm proud to say
I am a woman entrepreneur.
SPEAKER 6: And making
sure that others are also
encouraged to be a part of
this, that's a huge deal.
SPEAKER 19: Even
the speakers, we
are getting the female
expertise in technology.
It gives me so much happiness to
be a part of women tech-makers.
SPEAKER 1: A
developer in India is
someone who is really keen on
developing something good that
will be used by millions
of people around the world.
SPEAKER 13: My contribution as
a developer would be finding
new drug for cancer patients.
SPEAKER 20: Becoming
an engineer,
I can add a lot of
value to many lives.
SPEAKER 3: It's exciting.
If you get to do what you want,
it's all just exciting and fun.
SPEAKER 6: Go GDD India!
ALL: See you next year.
Bye bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]